um okay so teenager who murdered
boyfriend in a 100 mile per hour crash
had a toxic relationship with him the
prosecutor said McKenzie schrill a
19-year-old from Ohio was found guilty
of 12 counts including four counts of
murder for intentionally crashing her
car at 100 miles hour in July of 2022
resulting in the death of her boyfriend
Dominic Russo and his friend Davon
Flanigan prosecutors argued that shrill
had a toxic and tumultuous relationship
with Russo including violent threats and
she deliberately crashed the car to end
their relationship during the trial
security video of the crash was
presented as evidence the judge strongly
condemned schill's actions
characterizing the crash as methodical
deliberate and intentional and
purposeful the judge stated that this
was not reckless driving but an act of
murder emphasizing that the deliberate
nature of the crash and its devastating
consequences some key quotes and details
from the case include her actions were
controlled methodical deliberate
intentional and purposeful this was not
reckless driving this was murder said
the County Common Please judge Nancy
Margaret Russo she had a mission and she
executed it with Precision the mission
was death judge Russo added chill's
father expressed a desire not to see
chill's life ruined and called her
actions a damn stupid thing incidents
highlighted in the trial included shr's
threats to crash the car in the weeks
leading up to the fatal crash in videos
from Russo's cell phone capturing
vertial abuse and threats from shrill
Shilla had posted on social media
expressing her grief over Russo's death
and remorse for her actions with
statements like I miss you nug I wish
you were just going to walk through the
door any second please wait for
me so women are much more violent and
much more calculated than we give them
credit for and I think one archetype
that I see in society is the enabling
father and this is the father that
constantly babies and caters to his
daughter he puts his daughter on a
pedestal as a princess that can do no
wrong to the point where you have a dad
referring to murder as a damn stupid
thing however typically these dads if
they had a son that did the same thing
and killed a load of women they would
have a lot less empathy for them and
realize that when you commit a crime you
have to do the time but women are so
used to being bailed out of their bad
decisions and for a lot of women it
starts at Birth it starts at Birth when
their parents treat them differently
than the boys in the family and really
we have such a gynocentric social order
that we say to young women you are so
special and amazing and awesome all the
time even if you've done nothing nothing
to deserve it and enabling fathers lead
to bratty daughters that is why you have
the children throwing temper tantrums
that is why you have the children doing
things like this because they have a
lack of discipline in their life